Boeing will temporarily stop making its
troubled 737 max jet next month a
decision that could have a big impact on
the US economy tens of thousands of jobs
are linked to the airliners production
the 737 max as you may recall was
grounded in March after software issues
were tied to two deadly crashes that
killed 346 people Kris Van Cleave is in
Washington with more on this story good
morning to you Chris has caught a lot of
people by surprise so what does this
mean for workers now well good morning
for now the 12,000 Boeing employees who
work on the 737 will not face layoffs or
furloughs but boeing has 600 suppliers
so this move could impact tens of
thousands of supply chain jobs across
the country it's been 22 years since
boeing has had to temporarily halt
production of an airplane the 737 max is
estimated to account for about one third
of Boeing's revenue over the next five
years for months the company has said if
the max grounding was prolonged or
stretched into 2020 they'd have to
consider cutting production back in
April Boeing slashed output by 20
percent but they've built about 400 of
these 737s they cannot deliver to
Airlines until the FAA certifies the
plane as safe CEO Dennis Muhlenberg
tweeted we're keeping our employees
customers and supply chain top of mind
as we prioritize safely returning the
max to service the FAA is currently in
the process of reviewing Boeing's design
changes to the airplane certification is
possible sometimes in it sometime next
year and just this morning Southwest
Airlines joined American in removing the
Macs from its flight schedule until at
least April Tony we do hope people keep
their jobs Chris thank you very much now
a frightening malfunction forced an
emergency landing for a United Airlines
flight video from a passenger shows what
looks like flames shooting out of an
engine on United flight 366 the Boeing
737 left San Diego Sunday night it was
bound for Chicago but it only made it as
far as Albuquerque United is calling it
a mechanical issue clearly it is yeah
what you don't want to see 30,000 plus
feet in the air that's very very scary
I'd say